i'm so happy
that i literally just
i am not kidding i have this weird thing
that's been happening to me uh lately
which is i'm skipping
it's like what genuine happiness does to
it physically takes over
speaking of physical my trainer called
this morning and canceled and i was like
oh yes
so it's gonna be a great day all right
we're also having pop quiz one of my
favorite things to do on this show
during our final segment we're gonna ask
three questions about things that were
said and done during the hour so get
your mental
paper and pad and pencils out
and uh one person will be chosen and if
they answer one or two correctly it's a
hundred dollars for every answer that's
correct a thousand if you get all three
games are fun and uh i'm so excited but
if you really just want a fantastic
prize look no further
than our first guests and i do say
plural because there's a few of them
one of them happens to be a living
legend a grammy award winner and a
trailblazer
for the latin arts and culture and
joining her are two very special women
who i deeply admire and i'm honored to
say that they're here for the second
time
um because we all started our shows last
year in the pandemic
but some really special things have
happened to all of us along the way that
i can't wait to get into it's our
friends gloria lilly and emily step one
all right
[Applause]
thank you i love this is why people
think i'm a little kooky but i don't
care because it's true i'm so
happy to see you guys i mean we all
started our shows last year in the
middle of the pandemic it was a miracle
right
it is a miracle honestly and
two things have happened to both of us
um
that i'm so excited about
congratulations on getting a season two
yay
just started last week oh my god yes and
i felt like our sister shows um
we all got nominated for emmys
[Applause]
miracles on miracles you know when we
had our first um
hang last year
and with what i think the red table talk
you know institution um has built over
these years is the ability to leave it
on the table to have these profound
discussions
and
at a time when in some ways there's
social media tmi
so much being put out there where are
the substantive
takeaways where are the conversations
that leave us raw and vulnerable make us
feel less alone and also
teach us something i always love my
experts because we i mean the show is
about conversation and sharing the
perspective of three different
generations of in our case latin women
in this world that we all inhabit
but at the same time you know there's
you you have to make that connection
with the viewer and uh
i yeah i didn't make a connection last
week no yeah right with you know
gloria's um
you know the first episode first episode
it's been incredible yeah being betrayed
by trusted adults and and you know the
night before that's another thing she
calls us sometimes the night before hey
i'm going to say this tomorrow i'm going
to go there you know and the producers
don't even know because when you have
people coming and being brave it's
almost infectious and you do feel less
alone and i made a formal request for 10
therapy sessions because i may have
learned too much about my parents sex
life this season because i feel aloud i
feel very alone hold on
that doesn't mean i answered all right
yes you did okay oh
no
yes i asked all the questions
emily what do you mean i i do really on
your knees
and people want to know i do really i
didn't want to know okay i told you to
stay home and they said no she's got to
get
listen she walked off the table a couple
of times exactly i i did my best drew
but i don't know you guys will tell me
when the show comes out
what i do know is you started this
season off um with a true
force
and you made a really big splash on your
foray of season two
by disclosing such
heavy beautiful important
necessary topics so will you tell us
about episode one of season absolutely
drew look i i always tell everybody when
claire
crawley was gonna come on to talk about
what she experienced at the hands of a
priest when she was five years old
i i thought to myself i can't sit here
quietly and you know hypocritically
being quiet and keeping what i went
through and i thought okay
i can be an example for women and by the
way it's one in three women because
we've learned more statistics since we
did the show
it's one in three women and one in four
or five boys
that experiences some kind of abuse now
we know because we know of because those
are the ones that speak about it and i
thought you know i've had a wonderful
beautiful life filled with love filled
with support and i want anyone that's
gone through this to realize that
whatever trauma or terrible thing you
went through does not have to define you
now let me ask you a question and by the
way on a side note gloria
we were discussing it in the room before
we came out here and you know the fact
that you waited until your mom's passing
to bring this up
um
someone asked a question like oh was it
because of this and i was like i just
tapped right into my mom gut and i said
i bet it was because
this was not that this was something she
didn't want to have her mom relive why
why
and she was very traumatized drew
because i think she had a lot of
feelings of oh my god am i guilty of
putting her in that how is she gonna
know
but every time i would approach the
subject with her just because i had some
questions
she would really she'd start crying out
you know i can't deal with it so imagine
if i were to bring the public scrutiny
that this brings and i guess when you
shared um that abuse that you endured so
bravely you know that came into my life
and that's going to be in my child's
life because she says you know you have
to think about the way the intention of
the way somebody touches you that's a
core value of my life so for to share
with everybody else it's interesting to
be a parent now myself and realize how
overprotective you want to be as a
parent so i know thank you for having
these conversations thank you for
helping us all
deal with the things that we actually
have to as parents and we can't run away
from them now are there any topics for
you that are off limits for season two
oh
i don't know if it's so much off limits
as well when we choose our topics we try
to
make sure there's a value that we can
bring to the viewer a discussion that's
going to make them think or offer some
you know
things that are also evergreens that are
going to stand
the test of time
i also think that we go to places that
there are no limits and we need to
figure them out like we had some
conversations this um this batch of
episodes for example we talked about
colorism in the latin community which is
something that within that world is
hardly ever talked about because people
are afraid and uncomfortable there's not
even a war so we're colorful in spanish
right because it's the racism within our
own community families that have one
child that's so much darker than the
other and they're receiving different
treatment because of which you know
because of that so those conversations
people are afraid to have them but we
also want to go places that people are
afraid to go so these conversations are
available somewhere
[Music]